tenez vous aimez dorothée tient
pour régler quoi le disque c 30 francs
monsieur mais je ne vous ai rien non
mais je sais bien c'est dorothée camille
cette technique de vente au point c'est
de la vente directe et alors alors on
donne un disque aux enfants et les
parents la taille en sortait jamais
chérie tu aimes neurotech c'est pour toi
ces 30 francs madame ces dames en direct
maintenant je n'ai pas le droit de
reprendre le disque à l'enfant dorothée
m'interdit de reprendre des disques que
j'ai donné un anormal dans la série et
c'est dorothée voie lactée mais cette
technique ou
quoi
dorothée lé pa petit c'est ce qu'elle
fait c'est dorothée camion
pompe alors c'est de dire comme ça aux
gens on les met pas la main puis à dire
après ces trente francs et c'est de
retourner c'est à dire c'est 30 francs
merci hein c'est pour moi vous me le
donner withings en direct et dorothée
camille cette vente au point pour se
faire des couilles en or
vous êtes obligé où l'avait touché
madame j'ai pas de monnaie je vous
ordonne 3g pas de monnaie alors je vais
demain club dorothée je veux te l'engin
pays j'ai un vibromasseur qu'est-ce que
je le stérilet dorothée qui vient de
sortir vous voulez quoi qu'est ce que
vous voulez
aller jouer sur l'autoroute les enfants
en diable dorothée n'aime pas les
enfants alors foutez lui la paix à
dorothée 1 tiens c'est pour vous
voilà non c'est 30 francs madame
pouvait m'arriver s'il vous plaît j'ai
pas loin de reprendre madame dorothée
m'interdit de reprendre les disques que
je donne aux enfants c'est pas bon pour
son image c'est dorothée qui a mis cette
technique en pointe et à ma chérie il
faut pas que maman dont vous êtes les
chante avec vos enfants et à mon chéri
c'est pourquoi
j'ai pas mal de reprendre mon poème
régler s'il vous plaît mais
plaignez-vous à dorothée si vous n'êtes
pas contente regardez vous laisser aller
la faire pleurer mais j'allais rendre
entre enfants malheureux
ce principe c'est dorothée qui a mis ses
principaux quoi
c'est débile en plus
on en pêche que ça rapporte du pognon et
c'est ça le principal elle est à deux
doigts de pleurer c'est moi qui tu
lofteuse hop je l'espérais de ma poche
m
[Applaudissements]
alors laurent je vais te dire la vérité
c'est à dire la vérité je pensais à la
suite de cette séquence te demander de
venir s'excuser mais je pense que la
réaction de dorothée était quand même
beaucoup plus drôle et malin j'ai un
début d'érection match
bravo doit été dit je me mouille pas
dans les sujets sans conteste en
allemand je crois que dorothée eu la
bonne réaction c'est vrai on applaudit
dorothée
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu